all right yeah I figure of patients in
each email the basin is God who hired
her into the background by the enzymes
padded top come over here come on
hi
Emily
a new system which is very good for this
is asked first
every five people all RPC schools and
drove on Jesus that infinitely class
people those who are known as identity
also the video business class digital
neighbor tech up to cover three days and
master hot-dogging it saw a gentleman
Tony how are you my pleasure work it's
creating enough agency exam one year old
half years old after the end before he
goes for all the sandwich and all have
the PLO open he was longer than his
house we drove in lock a car they Maria
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are we gonna meet between y'all want to
do with Congress they just wanted me but
associate need initiative it is yes and
know how I work
go here for cocktail and he our car
[Music]
again we have an additional four
questions out very perfect to go to get
our net to be always both license
appears in August then Python talk about
the newsletter that's the kind that
worked in our the throw a little fumble
around after the meet up we really
wanted head can proofread are all right
the top 10 through 3 are is a little be
a nice I'm hardly here talk and lastly I
could get away we have two extra large
shirt
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so with that I'll say our
feature organizer part of our agencies
private organizations are bullfrog
[Music]
[Applause]
so first can everyone hear me with my
two mics yep looking good
all right so hi everyone I'm Emily
Robinson I'm a data analyst at HP and
today I'm going to talk to you a bit
about a/b testing so you know working at
Ft is great we have such wonderful teams
including our legal team which is why I
have this next slide
since the disclaimer so this talk
represents my own use not that of SD all
right you can go over so a bit of an
overview of what I'll be talking about
I'm first going to give a quick
introduction to absolutely because
that's where a lot of my examples come
from another introduction to a/b testing
and then go on to the challenges and
lessons that you can find with a/b
testing those statistical and business
so what is se so this is our tagline so
we're an online marketplace for handmade
vintage and craft goods so we don't own
any we don't keep any inventory
ourselves or rather we connect sellers
and buyers all around the world to each
other and so our items can range pretty
widely so it goes from this 5.0 sign
which is one of our most popular search
terms for those of you who don't know
this is the whole phenomenon a lot of
stores are running out of glue you can
see here if you go for like five or nine
dollars then you have some groomsmen
gifts these are handmade with leather
monogrammed and finally all the way up
to a $35,000 engagement ring so there's
just a really wide range of items that
you can get on the site and so strong
numbers people here are some of our
numbers so we have 1.8 million active
sellers 29.7 million active buyers which
means someone has made a purchase in the
past year 2.8 4 billion in annual GMS
GMS stands for gross merchandise sales
so that $35,000 engagement ring.if
itself is $35,000 GMS well FB only gets
three point five percent of that that
money the rest goes to the sellers
count GMS is one of our key metrics and
finally we have one in 45 millions items
for sales you know those three I showed
you were just some small examples so a
be testing so I'm going to walk you
through an example of what it is
so AP testing is where a company wants
to test how effective a change is or
even if it's effective at all and this
can range from pretty small it's much
larger changes so this is Sam and Sam
logs on and goes to SP one day and we're
running an a/b test and you can see one
of two things so you can see this Add to
Cart symbol on the left or this one on
the right bit of the spot the difference
is you can see this was just a small
color change we did you might notice by
this presentation
excuse brand color is orange and so we
change some of our buttons from green to
orange and the price from green to black
so this is a pretty small change but we
still test it out we want to make sure
that you know didn't have any adverse
effects but that was more of a
foundational change so we can do it for
new features and bigger things too so it
used to be if you start selling out Etsy
and there were no results this is a page
you would get so it would say we
couldn't find any results for those here
are some alternatives and the
alternatives were just served up
basically by chopping off words from
your search term so we wanted to offer a
better experience than this so what we
try is redirecting you so now if you
search that same search term because
we've launched the fast run in the
experiment you will see instead it will
say okay now we're showing results cute
sneakers for puppies we couldn't find
small cute sneakers or puppies but if we
didn't get it right if you actually
wanted something else we offer you some
alternatives so a/b testing is really
widely used so it's used all the big
technology companies as well as smaller
companies and non tech companies because
a qubit and Optimizely down they're just
one of many companies that offer
experimentation platform so for LinkedIn
at Ft Facebook Amazon we all have
usually our own experimentation team
internally with our own built platforms
but for companies that can't do that
optimized me and cubed and others offer
a way for them to also take advantage of
a/b testing it's pretty well researched
so when I was starting out a/b testing
at Ft one tweet a lot of papers and
there certainly are a lot we have some
written by LinkedIn keep like Cubitt
Google Microsoft so they are basically
publishing about you know what they've
learned and challenges they've
encountered now when I first went into
it I come from the Social Sciences so I
was doing experimentation and I had to
deal with small sample sizes I had to
recruit participants and there's a lot
of criticism sometimes about psych
research question if you're doing them
on undergrad that is a representative
you're not measuring the real outcome of
interest etc so I was thinking I might
ask you now we have millions of visitors
daily you know we have a data
engineering pipeline set up so basically
I don't have to do any of the work of
the ETL we extract transform load
process so essentially every night when
people come to the site every night we
bundle up all the events that they did
on the site we put those into visits we
assign those visits we say whether they
were in a certain experiment where they
in the control of the treatment and then
are the statistics or even calculated
for us so all of this is set up the
biggest thing I thought all right this
is a piece of cake you know why do they
even need us here the specs are all
aggregated the tests are done what can
be so hard well you know a theme of this
talk is generating numbers is easy but
generating numbers you should trust is
hard and generating the right numbers
and making the right interpretation
that's why I'll be talking about but I
was wanted on so why specific anyway so
this is some something that would sense
the Microsoft experimentation team they
said basically elections surveys are
done with a few thousand people right
and you and other big companies you have
millions of people like it can't you
just tell Ryan just look at the numbers
and it becomes very obvious you know if
you can do this with a thousand people
and forecast the outcome of elections
the last one notwithstanding you know
why why can't you do it here
well the thing is we're targeting very
small effect so for example at FC and
this conversion rate is not our
conversion rate so conversion rate by
the way those you don't know which is
percentage of people that buy as an
example we might target something like
this where we want to go from six to six
point zero three 0.5% change right not
six to nine percent not six to seven
percent six two point six point zero
three and the reason we target such
small effects is those are actually very
meaningful to us
millions of dollars annually but as you
can imagine it's really hard to stare at
that number and say whether that's
different or not without any sort of
test applied so Fleur I need statistical
tests so I'm going to go through an
example experiment that we recently ran
so I work with the search team at FC so
I have done work around our ranking
algorithms that order our search results
to new changes to our search user
interface and one thing we want to do is
we want to update our listing cards so
when you did a search how you saw the
listings represented and this is a bit
of a spot the differences so we did here
was actually four changes bundled
together so we made the price bigger we
made the title to lines instead of one
we added the shop rating so the numbers
of rating and the average reviews and
finally we took away the border and what
happened so we we launched this
experiment and we give it a week and we
see you know our our key metrics move
and it didn't work
so everything remain neutral except
clicks which actually went down now of
course the question here you want to ask
is why you know why did this happen and
so this is one of the hard parts when
you bundle four changes together so you
know when you just do one change it's
still pretty hard to answer why it may
be that might be a better question for
qualitative research actually but
especially when you're multiple changes
it could be any one of them or
combination so my guess was it's the
rating you know people now see the
rating that used to be you had to click
on the item and then go to the listing
page to see - so maybe we're just losing
these non valuable clicks people who
would have clicked found that all the
shop doesn't have a higher rating as I
would like and less so that's why we
didn't see any change the number of
people buying this is hypothesis so we
did was we ran an experiment again and
now we changed it so in one variant we
have to line title and no ratings and
the other variants we have the readings
and one line title and want to see how
that did and so you know I was coming in
expecting okay maybe neither of them are
going to do well but if either of them
does well it's going to be the one on
the left and you know why we do
experimentation I was wrong so that one
did kind of the same as the first one
and this one did well and we improved
our key metrics and click-through rate
and so we celebrated we watched so
that's just walking
through kind of a day in life of
something that I've worked on recently
so now on to the challenges so first
question is what is your level of
analysis for an experiment so I say
conversion rate the other metrics
click-through rate okay so those are you
know denominator numerator what are the
units of analysis and an experiment name
and we have [ __ ] with your cookie or
your device ID and that's always how we
determine what you see whether it's a
control or treatment because we don't
want you you know
seeing an inconsistent experience
experience while the experiment is
running but we slow the choice then so
we can look at the visit so this is an
activity by a browser ever defined
period of time for 30 minutes and what
that means is if I come to FD and I
search and running a search ranking
experiment now I'm bucketed Sam bucketed
into the variance and I go and I got a
cup of coffee I come back 45 minutes
later and I click on something but now
if I click on that that's going to start
a new visit because it's been more than
30 minutes of inactivity so we can look
at the browser level so the cookie or
device ID so this is the same thing that
we bucket on so in this case I would
still be one browser you know coming
back it wouldn't we start the clock and
finally you can do user so user is
assigned an user ID so I'm not going to
talk as much about the user because that
doesn't work for a company like Etsy
generally so and why I say that is s use
a website which you can do basically
everything being logged out so you can
now even buy something on se you could
always browse and do a lot of the
behavior without ever logging in so user
works really well for a social network
company so that creates buffer Lincoln
where really to use the site you need to
be logged in but for a company like FC
would just exclude a lot of our visitors
from the experiment so I'm going to
focus on talking about visited browser
so simple so here we have Liz and Liz
thinks and lists things you know I
really want my own lightsaber so we're
just go Scouts FC and researches and
we're running a search ranking
experiment and so she's bucketed in
Cimmerian she sees all these lifesavers
she says wow I really like this one I'm
going to favorite it I'm going to buy it
and not buy em who could have favorite
it and leave that she's not ready to
commit
the vermin expiration comes back and
she's like you know I really like that
lightsaber she visited she visits her
favorite she doesn't do a search she
adds to cart and she buys and we all
celebrate now what's happened here is if
you were looking at from evaluating the
experiment this would count as one visit
because only one of the time she came to
the site did she do a search and it
would be a non converting visit because
she didn't buy on the other hand she
would be one browser who did buy so this
is in a you know real-life example of
how the metrics could look different
depending on how we evaluate it so how
do we think about which one we choose
I'm going to go through some of the
benefits and drawbacks of each so for
the visit you have a tighter attribution
so when you only look at things that
happen within session that within a
session that includes the change that
you introduced you can be a little more
confident it came because of your change
because you're not looking at much later
behavior now on the flip side as we tell
us is sometimes that later behavior is
related to the change that you made and
that's the advantage of browser so it
captures this later behavior that is
very relevant visit has a problem some
of you might have picked up on which is
the independence violation assumption so
and what this is here is that you know
the physical tests you use they assume
each unit in our analysis is independent
of each other but of course you know
sailors have come back and searched ten
times on Etsy
now that would count as ten visits but
obviously they're not independent of
each other
and so this can lead to a big increase
in your false positive rates and there
are some workarounds for that so what we
do with our app experiments for example
is we bootstrapped them but basically
what we know liz is the same person she
came and visited twice our ten times so
we can bootstrap on a browser ID you
thought but that is an issue which is
sort of naively doing visits and browser
on the other hand can introduce noise so
let's say we are running an experiment
that targeted a much smaller section of
the site and we ran it over three weeks
and let's say someone entered the
experiment when they went to the section
of the site but that was on the first
day and they haven't gone back since and
three weeks later they buy something you
know did that really come from our
experiment probably not but we're still
counting it as having
you know towards our experimental
metrics finally for visit we have a
cannibalization potential as you might
have noticed when I said with Liz she
had one visit not the two that she did
because only one of them involved search
so what could happen here is you could
just shift people's purchases around so
you know search allow you the kids a
visit level assuming really well but
what you could be missing is that they
would have bought anyway just maybe at a
later time in another way say by going
to our our shop home or by a different
way of buying and finally for browser
probably here is you can miss multiple
events for proportion metrics so
conversion rate right it's a binary
metrics did you buy or did you not buy
and if Liz came and bought six times
during the course of our experiments
you'll still only count as one
converting browser so overall we've
decided that we offer both so we have an
internal experimentation tool called
catapult and basically what you can do
is every day updates and you can look
and you can see the results for your
experiment so you can see the control
versus your variance the rates for each
metric and the calculated statistical
test for whether it's significant or not
so we always even people can see both
visit and browser but we generally
emphasize using browser and so one way
we started to solve for this missing
multiple event with making a metric that
we call HDTV and I'll go into a little
bit because what's one of our key
metrics per user well photo don't
surprise you that it's gross merchandise
sales are GMS per user so the problem is
this is a very badly behaved
distribution so if you think about it
it's highly skewed so you have some
people purchasing that $35,000
engagement ring but most people you know
purchase items a much lesser value
strictly non-negative you can't have a
negative interaction you can't buy
something for a minus ten dollars on the
site so you can't use the t-test and as
a lot of zeros a lot of people who don't
buy so you can't simply log all the
numbers so what we did was we created
this metric we called average converting
browser value or average converting
visit values so this is the distribution
for it and this is over different time
periods so say a couple days or two
weeks of browsers what's the of the
browsers that bought something what was
their value
and the thing you can see here right
away is it's still very skewed so now
it's strictly positive it's still quite
skewed and this is actually with the
outliers cutoff so this isn't even as
skewed as a distribution here is we cut
off the the very extreme right tail and
the question is okay what test you use
for this and how do you figure that out
so what we did was we tried a couple
different ones and so I want to walk
through quickly some definitions then we
have a wide range of backgrounds here so
just a bit of a review so power
probabilities if there's an effect of a
certain magnitude we're going to detect
it
so that was fine you're very concerned
about with our test because if we
actually move this metric we wanted to
make sure that we would know that and so
we wanted to take a test with very good
power bootstrapping random sampling with
replacement and simulation is a way to
model random events and this will all
come into play with how we develop this
past so what we did to select the right
test we took a real experiment that we
are very confident actually move this
metric because of the change we
introduced so we use that as our
baseline we have a control and a variant
there and we we know that the the
overall truth of that is that a CBD
increased the variance and what we then
did was we applied a lot of different
tests and we estimated the power of it
and we did this by bootstrapping so we
said okay we had a real number so we did
a real number of browsers that converted
let's say it was 100,000 in each variant
but we said okay but what all right so
let's you know if we randomly sample and
replace with this and did that a
thousand times how many times would we
detect with different tests that there
was a change and okay now we do that for
a hundred thousand have a twenty five
thousand how about if our sample size
have been five hundred thousand you know
we do all this bootstrapping so we can
get an idea of okay what percent of the
time is our test giving us back p-value
of less than point zero five so I know
there the axolotl smaller eat here where
you have on the left its power on the X
X access to the sample size and the and
basically what you can see pretty easily
is one tested terribly that was a t-test
not too surprising here with this
terribly skewed distribution and then
two tested very well so it did really
well here was
t-tests of the log of the numbers and
the wilcoxon rank-sum test so we now
have an idea of okay these two tests
seem like they're going to do pretty
well but that's for our specific
experiment with the specific percentage
change that we had so how can we expand
this to other experiments that we might
do and what we did for that was
simulation but of course question is
okay stimulating means okay how can we
we have a control okay how can we
estimate what it would look like this
distribution if there was a 1% change
and a lot of choices you have here a
different simulation methods so we tried
out a bunch of them and basically what
we did here was we said okay the
difference looks like the difference in
means from the real treatment group and
the real control group okay we have a
distribution for that now let's try out
how it would look
from the control to all our different
simulation methods and let's see which
ones match the best and that's going to
give us a good idea of okay which is a
good simulation metric and you can see
there are a couple different things
because there's difference and the
regular means the log means but
basically overall we found that two
works very well which is a simulation
with a log normal method and just a
straight multiplication like I'm just
multiplying the numbers by one percent
every number but actually did pretty
well so now what happens when we look at
the power so we we try doing this
simulation for you know to replicate our
true experiment and see how it compares
and what we see is the one in the middle
there is the true experiment power curve
and it's bounded by our two simulation
methods so one is more conservative so
power glut lower and one is higher
basically this helps us form the
confidence bounds so now we were able to
say okay if we have a real 1% change in
ACB V what is going to you know how much
power we going to have in this forms of
power bonds now that will go two steps I
know we have some staff speed cheese in
here it's probably going to be the most
exciting part the rest of the experiment
the rest of presentation salt less
statistics heavy and actually and talk
about the business challenges so those
of you in data science or research or
any kind of technology might
yes the technical skills are hard and
important but the other big part is your
business skills and communication on
working with teams and if you don't have
those skills it can actually be very
hard to advance to be very effective in
your job so when I came to SB so as I
said I work with different teams so at
C's analytics work where we embed with
other partner teams and so I've embedded
with the search team and one thing my
manager told me we're good teams are
each a special snowflake so that's what
I want to go first so I've worked with
three different teams now all in search
and the working style that they have and
what they know is all very different but
there are a couple things I've learned
that I think can apply pretty broadly so
first is the importance of proactive
communication so coming from both of you
that's a two-sided thing and what could
help with that is developing a
relationship so understanding your
teammates what I mean by that some
questions you might want to ask okay how
certificate we minded our day how much
do they know about analytics you know
how much do they you know feel that you
are part of a team with them or that you
are some outside gatekeeper and helps
develop that relationship what you want
to do is help demonstrate value so you
don't want to be somebody just kind of
swooped in and it's like a your
experiment was effective or it wasn't
effective because where you can actually
be the most helpful is sometimes in the
beginning of the process you can help
with prioritizing different plans that
they want to do you help say okay is
this even possible with the data we have
we even measure this and finally you can
help with sequencing so for example if
they are interested in two experiments
and one is introducing new filters and
one is another experiment meant to
increase filter usage well you probably
want to put the increasing filter usage
one first because you'd imagine any new
filters are only going to be so
effective as much as people use them and
other ones you want to get this early
involvement all right three no
post-mortem comes from a Robert Fisher
quote where he said to ask a
statistician to evaluate an experiment
after it's finished it's ask him to
conduct a post-mortem you can amost tell
you what it is died of and I think this
is a really important point
fortunately hasn't happened to me aware
they come and say oh we already ran it
it's great stopped in a week you know
but now we want to know XYZ I'm like
well we didn't measure X
during the experiment so we can't really
do that but you know even early
experimentation doesn't just mean okay
they tell you or you're involved the day
before they run the experiments but
again trying to get involved very early
to make sure okay everything they want
to measure can they measure it
do they need to fire a new event so
something we've done is you know you can
fire back end or a fun and event so I
want to record filter usage a couple
different ways you can do that so let's
make sure we're at least doing it one
way and that way you can just be much
more effective working with them so next
John IV I've developed is dealing with
ad hoc questions what I mean by that is
getting a question like you know what's
the conversion rate of people in Estonia
on a Saturday looking in the wedding
category so something just you know it's
long that you don't have offhand or that
doesn't take you know literally at this
point there are some very basic
questions that I can get at any point
like okay all right I'd like a report on
that you know any sequel here you go
but so what do you do with these
questions that don't fall into that my
first response I say what decision are
you using this for and why do I do that
it's really two reasons the first does
it helps avoid the situation where I
would look a bit much less happy than
Harry but basically where you're just
overloaded with questions and requests
and you can't get done sort of longer
term more impactful work but the other
reason is it checks the translation what
I mean by that is some I fall on Twitter
and she's not okay she has a five where
she says you know part of our job as
data science a data analyst is take a
business question translate it to a data
question find the data answer and
translate it back to a business answer
but what happens sometimes is you get a
due to question and they may not
actually realize that that is not going
to answer their their third question so
what this does is this helps you check
the translation because if you ask what
is the business motivation behind this
decision or this question that you're
asking me you may help some say one of
two things one okay even it's not even
necessarily that important or you know
that sorry like I there are other higher
priority projects I have but in other
cases you say oh actually you don't want
this metric you want this one or I think
this is a better direction to go and
help you and so you know this is a
little example of kind of my day to day
but the other big part of course is as I
said I work with teams on their
experimentation and I think the
Microsoft platform team experimentation
platform team put it best when I said
some that doesn't work sometimes our job
is to tell science that their new baby
is ugly and what I'm invited well you
know so there's books parties and
experiences often a lot of investment in
in them and what I mean is occasionally
there can be financial investment so if
the team you're working with if they
have certain goals set let's say okay
our experiments are going to lead to X
amount of incremental money for our
company by the end of the quarter a
financial investment maybe even their
bonuses tied to that but even putting
that aside there's just this emotional
investment that's because people build
things that they think are going to be
useful right they're not just throwing
things out the wall they spent a lot of
time on this they're smart people they
put effort into you know this experiment
but they often have inaccurate
expectations because what they don't
realize is that most experiments fail so
not included all the big companies you
know Google Amazon here with lots of
lots of smart and hardworking people the
end of the day we run experiments
because we don't know what's going at
work so the success story is often much
less than 50% and not even a success
rate of ideas so if you talk about
individual experiments it goes down and
so with this emotional investment you
know come some things like kicking so
kicking is where you look at the results
before they're ready it's all going to
questions is what what do the results
means very normal question but my answer
might be has been up for 15 minutes
let's wait a little bit and of course
this is very much a do what I say not
what I do so you know I'm usually the
first one checking results wanting to
make sure everything's working I'm also
a bit invested but I can kind of pull
myself back so the strategy I have for
dealing with this as I said earlier our
experiment results update once a day
basically one you get in the morning you
get a cup of coffee you can go to our
catapult page and you can see basically
okay yesterday how did we do how did
that add on to the previous days so what
I've started doing recently is sending
daily experiment update and this helps
two things the first thing is it offers
interpretation so often people will be
looking at these numbers and not
necessarily knowing what they mean like
okay is it a problem it's been three
days and I don't see a win yet or I see
this metric move but not this one you
know maybe on the vigil is about the
browser level you know what's happening
here and so what I can help offer and
part of my job is to say okay you know
don't worry about this or we still need
to run the experiment for a little
longer or maybe wait everything looks
like it's converged and we're ready to
make a decision and the second thing is
it shows that you're monitoring so it
just shows what you're on top of it that
yes you're aware of what's going on you
know and so they don't have to worry too
much that something's happening and no
one's checking in on it again so why not
I peek well they want to make fast
decisions and this makes sense so if
they have something so say we roll out a
future and the ground truth is it does
really well
well we're experimenting we're not
showing it to everyone so if it's making
us extra money we want to show it to
everyone as soon as possible on the
other hand if we have a bad experience
playing that's not doing well we want to
bring it back as soon as possible
finally even if it's neutral we want to
we still want to ramp it down as quickly
as we can because that way it clears the
roadway a bit for other other
experiments but of course the problem
with this that they don't realize is a
cost of peeking so here we have graph
and it just shows okay this is where we
simulated thousands of experiments that
actually there was no difference between
a and B but what happens if you use the
p-value as a stopping rule to say okay
soon soon as T dips below point zero
five stop the experiments you can see
all those red squiggly lines you know a
lot of them are dipping below
significance way early even though on
the final day only 5% of them as you
would hope show significance so it just
really raises your false positive rate
so one thing we've been working on on
Hep C
is okay how can we help solve this
problem there's a couple ways we can do
you do kind of a really you know just
simple rule of adjust the p-value
threshold so the nice thing is easy to
interpret what I mean by this is set of
P equals point zero five let's say you
check every day okay now you have to
find P equals point 0 2 or 1/2 see below
P equals two point zero one so it's very
easy to interpret but it's not very
rigorous so I was like you know you
heard why I kind of said this is sort of
putting some arbitrary p value rules
there the other one is just outlawed
peeking saying no you can't do it either
we're just putting our foot down we're
not going to make a decision before two
weeks or even at the extreme does not
let people see the results so this is
the correct way to do it this how P
values are designed you can be set a
sample size or in our case that's been a
number of days and then you don't check
until that day that day you look p value
above or below point zero 5 you make
your decision but the big problem is you
miss bugs so something that happens is
maybe you're running experiment and
first day you see results you go oh no
you know we are supposed to be you know
we have this new filter and want to
message measure usage but it's saying
it's zero percent probably not actually
zero percent it must be that we're not
hiring or not recording when people use
this filter or otherwise we say okay
everyone in our variant should have an
event flying only seven 75 percent - oh
when I filter it by country it turns out
it's only working for us so that is
really one of the huge benefits of
seeing your spirit results early is you
can just catch these bugs very quickly
so the final solution is like called
continuous monitoring so this is
something that some Stanford professors
derived one of the companies I mentioned
earlier Optimizely uses this for their
experimentation platform and essentially
what this is is this is an always valid
p-value so it's a way that you can peek
and you can stay rigorous so you don't
have to do too much explaining about it
to the business partners such as they
can kind of checks when okay if it's
p-value less than point zero five then
we're good Palmer is a complicated to
influence and explain so if you're not
working with Optimizely for enough math
yourself if you put it in your
engineering
and the other thing is when I say
explain here you'd have to explain why
you know suddenly we're seeing a lot
fewer tests with the p-value less than
point zero five and that's going to
raise a lot of questions so with that
all being said we're still valuing what
the best method is it may be hybrid of
these or even more that I didn't mention
but I wanted to give an example of a lot
of companies faces kind of questions
when you're you know giving data science
products that people not trained in
statistics or data science and one
answer to this you can do education you
can do you can change your system so
there's a lot of options you have to go
with here and I want to say to end this
presentation you know at the end of the
day I love this product so this is just
a short end section of it which says is
the more programming I do the more I run
into things where I don't know Google
doesn't know my colleagues don't know
but guess what we still have to do it
and I say right this is why they pay a
human with a brain who can investigate
and learn and so that I think that's why
this field is so interesting is you know
it's not a place where you can go to the
back of the textbook and find the answer
we are trying to figure out okay we're
working right now how do we do GMs per
user
well pretty sure other companies have
done this or something similar with
revenue but if they have the not a
publishing it and so we have to do a
process like we did for HGTV and you
know sort of go our own way make our own
system and that can make it really far
if it also makes it really interesting
so if you want to learn more about a/b
testing I spent a couple resources here
so slides will be shared afterwards
these are all links so these are just
some of the experimentation papers that
I've talked about to get beginning
source published by companies like
Microsoft and LinkedIn some of them are
more technical than others would
actually find a lot of them are pretty
accessible to people with some you know
basic stats and data knowledge I also
want to thank everyone who helped me
with this presentation with the teens I
work with at FB and finally say thank
you to you all so here's the link to the
slide that's my blog and that's my
twitter handle and i'm happy to take any
questions either either more formally
right now or you can catch me afterward
I will be at the bar thank you very much
[Applause]
so price and buy price I assume you mean
like the price is it good right so
that's a very interesting topic so the
short answer it FC is no no we don't
test it on the buyers side so you don't
show buyers different prices and the
reason for that is partly we don't
control it so sellers set their own
prices but even a company is where
that's not the case I've heard that's a
very difficult thing to test on because
while it obviously gives you a lot of
good information your consumers are
going to get very angry if they realize
that some people are seeing cheaper
goods than they are so for the little so
I haven't looked too much into it just
because it doesn't apply as much at FC
but yes from what I read that playing
that's less common to be tested just
because in terms of almost PR standpoint
that you don't want your customers
feeling like wow I can trust the prices
or they'll probably start gaming the
system
yes so the question was how do you pick
what variables to prioritize you're
thinking of tasks to the slow process
that's a great question
so I will be quickly @fc so usually we
don't need very long to test our changes
so if you're a company that has a very
small amount of traffic and may take a
long time but not honestly it takes at
least a week and that's partly to
control for kind of weekly seasonality
so how do we choose prioritize so the
first thing we look at is what percent
of our traffic is it affecting so even
if we have out which is think there's
been a great change but it only applies
to people in Lithuania logging on
logging in on a Saturday you know even
if that increased their conversion rate
by 10% compared to a small increase on
our search page this gets a lot more
traffic it just wouldn't be done in
paxil that's kind of the first step we
do something called opportunity size and
we say okay if this led to a 1 percent
conversion rate change you know how much
money would that generate and that's
basically based on the traffic size and
the current rate of how much people buy
on that page but the other question is I
think this brings going back a little
bit on the speed so you know one in that
first example experiment I showed well
we bundled four things and usually you
know that's not the best practice and
you saw how that can go wrong that's one
way to speed it up as use try some
changes together but one of the reasons
we did that is the alternative was what
you know are we going to try each of
them at one and then are we going to try
each of them interacting with each other
maybe they don't work by themselves but
together they work really well and then
you would get 16 experiments so you know
sometimes what we do in order IRA type
thing is you say okay which which
changes do we think can go together and
we can we can sort of put them out as a
bundle even though we know theoretically
is not the best way to test this is just
the practicality of what we have to do
relevances raishin yes that's that's
really interesting yes so that's
certainly something else that I've seen
before and I think that's a little bit
of the continuous monitoring idea too
which is basically okay if the effects
big enough we can stop early right
because whenever you power test it's
assuming the effect size is a certain
amount say a 1% change but if we have a
10% change so we're going to know a lot
sooner because it's just a much more
dramatic change so so that's a little
bit on your question of like pharma and
so I think that is something we're
definitely looking into is okay how do
other industries or other people solve
this peeking problem and can you remind
me of the first part of your question
yes multi-factor design yes so that is
something that actually one of our
analysts is looking into now so how we
can basically try different combinations
variables in the most efficient way
possible I would say we we don't have
that implemented yet aside from sort of
just again like a simple design like
okay let's try out a multi variant where
you know we have you know variant where
we introduce change a one where each
introduce change B and the third one
where we do ad but that is something
we're looking at to help speed up
experimentation is doing the factorial
design
so I would say in choosing the metrics
so generally we have a set of key
metrics so basically this is even if
your experiment isn't targeting this we
have it on the experiment page so we
make sure you don't accidentally take
them and those key metrics are things
you'll make sense things like our you
know GM s our conversion rate and the
ACVB like how much value are people
buying so I would say in choosing what
metrics to use generally that's the
first one we go to is okay is it going
to move this main needle and then the
next one is some lower down thing so
sometimes we'll look at okay how can we
get you know we think we have some
really great so if you're talking at
filter usage up or occasionally we'll
have one so like okay let's just make
sure that nothing gets messed up like
the color change that was more
foundational with our design team wanted
to make a unit more unified site
experiment we didn't really think it
would increase people buying we're an
experiment to make sure that it didn't
have any negative effects I would say we
have pretty standard set of key metrics
although it does vary for different
groups so maybe if you're in the
autosuggest group again you're
monitoring the big key metrics but you
want more people to click our auto
suggestions so it does depend a little
bit on the team
yeah so I think so your question was
asking how do we control for the fact
that people might be seeing both
variants that way since we don't do
assigned in thing yeah so that's a great
question
so an example here would be like if
you're on your browser your Safari yet
work and then you go to Chrome on your
home laptop so you're not signed in you
might see two different variations so we
do make sure like okay while you're
still like while you're Sonia safari at
work
you're not seeing two different
variations but people use you know the
apps they use their home device etc so
the short answer is it's a really
difficult problem for people who aren't
signed in so for find in write you could
start controlling for this you can say
okay that's you know clearly you're the
same person but how do we do it first
signed out and so we've explored a
couple options of okay there are some
companies out there that help offer ways
for you to tell you know I think it's
based on location data or maybe like
some other logs in of okay this
film-like
links to this laptop is the same person
but you know then you you know we
haven't we've been evaluating that
ourselves because we can say okay let's
take how well does this do in the cases
where we know the truth like someone is
signed in are they matching them so
that's one Avenue we're working on but I
would say but overall you know outside
of that efforts is actually something
that we're currently not controlling for
and that's partly because at most we
could you know control that well for
only a small sub portion of our
population that signed in
sorry I can't hear about the mic again
thank you
mm-hmm
yeah so I would say we except for these
outside vendors like I mean we could try
things people have tried looking at more
behavioral thing but it's just hard when
we had so many millions of people we
don't have that much information on them
all the time right it's not like we're
getting there you know home address and
like oh they you know again if they
never login we don't know they logged in
at the same place but I think that's a
really good point and that is something
that we we worry about sometimes yeah so
we have so there's a couple different
parts like questions I was asking about
whoever looks the results by different
market segments and you know with that
do we ever
maybe release you know our change only
to a certain portion so first inserts or
internal tool actually allows us to
slice and experiment by a couple
different ways so we can look at you
know by your region by your language by
your on spire your Chrome etc but most
of the time that's a little more useful
for bug cashing or very extreme results
and part of that is because general
we're not powered to know those changes
because we generally run an experiment
about just as long as it takes to like
to text a a 1% change overall but then
of course if you start chopping up the
traffic you know we generally don't have
enough data that being said so I was the
most experiments generally target
everyone and usually we would launch to
everyone and let's again there's some
extreme thing that like oh my god we
broke this experiments with chrome and
like this doesn't load on Chrome
browsers but that's more of a bug that
being said there have been a few
experiments though some of our
experiments like with different
countries like how we you know we was in
a thing called local boots where
essentially you see more items from
someone in your country shipping cost is
cheaper etc that's wearing we've tested
and occasionally rolled out to certain
countries and not others Plus example we
did very targeted because you know maybe
this works for Italy but it doesn't work
for Germany and finally we also do some
things differently for new buyers on
Etsy and you know how we can measure new
buyers the way we're doing it now it's
not perfect with the best way is this
the first time we've ever seen your
cookie so they will see a different
experience experience partly that's
because you know we don't have recently
viewed items for them we don't have
recommendations from what they've done
but also because we think ok they need
to be served a little bit of a different
content about Etsy
yeah that's a good question is basically
do any post experiments monitoring and
the short answer is generally no and
actually we're at a data science talk
the other day and Facebook was up there
they say you know why do we run
experiments made this really nice graph
where it's like you know this product
managers think ok it's going to be a
flatline we launch our experiments goes
way up and then splat again so it's very
clear so experiment and the graph
actually looks like very squiggly and so
essentially what it boils down to is it
would generally be very hard to tell
because you know we could try doing a
time series analysis or predicting
without the experiment how would it go
but as I said we're not moving metrics
you know there's not it doesn't go from
6 to 7% it goes from 6 to 6 2003 so the
day after it rolls out it goes to 6.0 -
I mean that's just we have a lot of you
know that's very normal variation so I
would say I think that's a really
interesting idea and maybe I can talk
more about how you might tackle that
problem but right now we don't do that
yes so that's your question so it sound
like you know how do you when you're
embedding with teens kind of how do you
gain trust and buy-in and so I think
there's a couple of answers to this
question and the first thing is going
back to that snowflake side like I've
worked with two different teams and I've
had different relationships with them
and I don't feel I've necessarily
changed that much but just knowing going
in I think it's really good to know it's
a sensor it's you know it's not
necessarily all on you it's like they'll
have different working relationships and
it just might be you might never like
and that as much as you would maybe
they're in a different location where
there's other factors not being said I
think there's a couple things so I would
say we've never really had a problem of
buying of like we should run experiments
you know or you know we should trust our
analysts to interpret experiment results
generally and partly that's because as a
wider company fu3 data-driven so we you
know no team would kind of get by with
saying oh we generate twenty million
dollars in revenue and we just know this
because we launched the product so you
know I'm looking at some companies maybe
when their data science is a little
younger you do face that issue I haven't
faced that issue as much but that being
said I think you're going back a little
bit I think one thing is demonstrating
value and I think part of this can be
doing things that aren't necessarily
always the most interesting to you so we
have looker which is a business
intelligence tool basically interface to
the sequel innovates graph this is the
most exciting thing to me a program in
the world
not really that being said is it really
useful to help partner teams like that
these dashboards I get all this
information that was locked away before
yes and so I think you know sometimes
the data find you bugs you want to work
on like the coolest algorithms or you
know the most new difficult path rooms
can bury my head in the books for two
weeks and emerge and go back to my teams
and here you go I think it really helps
you get the band you know and you can do
that but I think what gives you the
runway to do that is demonstrating value
early on with some you know maybe a
little more boring or simpler things but
you know that will help them and
I think the final thing is just you know
the title size practice communication is
something I'm still working on but you
know realizing that you know there's
sort of a general business they're not
in your head and as much as you can
helping them and being very approachable
so never necessarily assuming or you
know making would make fun but but you'd
be like oh my gosh you don't know what a
power is or a p-value is but just being
seen as someone's very approachable and
happy to educate and then they'll be
willing to ask you those questions
instead of things going and making
decisions anyway
[Applause]